[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue à tous dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo l'émission
de la rédaction pour revenir sur
l'actualité départementale de la semaine
voici les titres de ce vendredi 27 avril
favoriser les circuits courts et
promouvoir le commerce local la
troisième édition de la fête
internationale des marchés est lancé
depuis ce vendredi à versailles les
parrains de l'événement était présent
pour l'occasion plus de 1000 marché
participent à l'événement cette année en
france un plan qualifiée de la dernière
chance jean louis borloo a dévoilé jeudi
son rapport pour les banlieues celui ci
doit permettre de réduire les inégalités
entre les territoires et encourager un
sursaut de la nation nous en parlerons
avec notre invité suzanne blanc vice
présidente de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines responsable de la
police politique de la vie notamment
dans le reste de l'actualité retour sur
l'installation de jean jacques brot en
qualité de nouveau préfet des yvelines
ou encore la restauration de l'église
saint-victor qui se poursuit à
guyancourt une journée classée orange
dans les deux sens la circulation sera
compliqué samedi sur l'ensemble du
territoire et particulièrement en ile de
france bison futé conseille d'éviter
notamment la zone du péage de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines en fin de
matinée fin d'après-midi le reste du
week-end jusqu'à jusqu'au 1er mai est
lui classé vert en revanche la galère
continue pour les usagers des transports
en commun les difficultés vont reprendre
jusqu'à lundi matin un nouveau préavis
de grève des cheminots l'état du trafic
sur vos lignes pour saint quentin en
yvelines est à retrouver sur
transilien.com pas noté que la direction
de la sncf doit annoncer aussi des
modalités de remboursement pour les
usagers à cause des perturbations
je vous en parlais dans les titres la
fête internationale des marchés 2018
débutera le 11 mai prochain le marché
notre dame à versailles tout juste élu
comme le meilleur d'île de france
participent à cette initiative qui vise
à valoriser le commerce local ce
vendredi les parrains de la fête
internationale des marchés ont parcouru
les allées du site versailles et les
allez plutôt du site versailles et
reportage de marion ptac et nicolas
dents
du fromage des légumes de la charcuterie
ou des pâtes fraîches les richesses du
marché notre dame de versailles des
produits inspirant pour les spécialistes
de la cuisine comme les parrains de la
fête internationale des marchés 2018 on
identifie ce que l'on va mettre à
l'intérieur de son corps sur un marché
c'est à dire que on ne mange pas de
manière anonyme
en mettant au four un plat pré pré pré
pré pré préparer et ans qui traverse
toutes les saisons on est là en train de
suivre le pouls on prend le pouls d'une
saison c'est un beau marché parce que je
trouve qu'il ya beaucoup des producteurs
directs et ça c'est très important je
suis vraiment pour le kilomètre zéro
consommer vraiment régionales et des
saisons les commerçants et producteurs
partage d'histoire des produits manière
de cuisiner ou de préserver la limande
des conseils donnés aux clients et on
adore le faire parce qu'il ya la
convivialité
on aime faire plaisir aux gens c'est un
vrai partage on les voit heureux à
travers les produits qu'on leur vend
donc tout ça ça nous rend heureux mais
écoutez je pense que c'est vraiment un
très beau marché et toutes les personnes
qui viennent ici sous immédiatement
conquis d'abord il est beau visuellement
et surtout il est beau et bon parce que
les produits sont de qualité près de 105
marché francilien participent à la fête
internationale des marchés
une opération prévue du 11 au 27 mai
vivre ensemble vivre grand pour une
réconciliation nationale ce n'est pas le
slogan d'une campagne présidentielle
cacher mais le titre du rapport de jean
louis borloo pour la banlieue rapport
remis
dit au premier ministre et qui comprend
19 programmes pour remettre la
république au coeur des quartiers
populaires et atteindre l'égalité
républicaine minimal sur l'ensemble du
territoire français selon son auteur
suzanne blanc bonsoir si vous n'êtes pas
l'auteur du rapt mais vous avez vice
président de saint quentin en yvelines
en charge notamment de la politique de
la ville vous êtes aussi première
adjointe à montigny le bretonneux
déléguée à la vie scolaire
comment vous avec votre expérience et
votre regard d'élu local vous avez
accueilli ce rapport à hier de jean
louis borloo alors déjà je vais tout à
fait honnête je ne vous cache pas que je
n'ai pas pris hier au soir comme livre
de chevet ceci étant j'ai regardé bien
sûr les grandes lignes bon ce sont des
préconisations après il va falloir
erreurs des arbitres à douala en mai
auraient besoin trash forcément
l'accent est mis sur la rénovation
urbaine accent est mis effectivement sur
l'éducation ça c'est vrai que c'est un
sujet qui qui m'intéresse beaucoup
il semblerait qu'elle vision globale
quand même qui se dégage le rapport a
été plutôt bien accueilli j'ai
globalement par les élus associations et
vous partager aussi cette vision qui
englobe l'ensemble du problème et pas
forcément accès sur un point je suis
assez d'accord avec vous dans la mesure
où c'est vrai que
politique de la ville on en parle depuis
40 ans enfin il ya quarante ans que ça
existe mais que la société évolue et que
donc par conséquent et jean louis borloo
est un homme intelligent il a il a dû
regarder toutes les facettes y compris
les nouveaux volets j'oserais dire de
notre société et ce à quoi il faut
répondre de la façon la plus urgente
alors jean louis borloo justement
attaque très fort dans ce dans ce
rapport dans son introduction dans les
interviews aussi qu'il a pu donner
ensuite il atteint que les élites
françaises la bureaucratie la république
en général qui l'accusent en gros un de
l'acheter il dit notamment là je le cite
dans le texte
il est clair que l'écart des chances
d'avenir selon les territoires les
origines sociales la géographie urbaine
ne cesse de croître et je suis
aujourd'hui la france est un pays plus
inégalitaires qui lie à 20 ou 30 ans
selon vous moi j'aurais pas tout à fait
ce sentiment quand même il a raison par
rapport au fait que certains décident de
choses alors qu'ils sont assis
chaudement derrière loeb
leurs bureaux surtout en hiver c'est
vrai qu'il faut être sur le terrain pour
voir les choses et les comprendre pour
voir les difficultés aussi pour voir la
vidéo qui pour certains habitants est
compliqué ça c'est un sujet qu'il
connaît bien et de la pratique est lui
même
donc voila et c'était un élu de terrain
et sa mise à part je trouve que quand on
a dit ça on a tout dit si on ne va pas
vérifié sur le terrain comment les
choses se passent ce n'est pas juste en
disant aux séquelles qu'elle quelques
bons rapports que ce soit qu'on arrivera
à régler les problèmes mais globalement
on a partagé pas forcément son son côté
alarmiste pour pour les pour la
situation des banlieues vous vous ai
déjà eu l'occasion de le dire même ici
je suis plutôt une optimiste de nature
alors j'espère qu'on avancera vraiment
qu'on arrivera à créer je crois qu'il
veut 250000 apprentis voilà tout ça ça
fait partie des possibles quelle est la
situation doit à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines justement il
ya cinq villes qui sont concernés par la
sortie sud de la ville y en a six alors
désormais avec avec plaisir voilà avec
plaisir et mon repas qui se sont donc
ajoutés en 2016 comme vous le savez à
l'agglo plus mais en politique de la
ville à proprement parler il ya
effectivement plaisir m europe 1 plus
sain quand on est venus que certains
quartiers sont sont dans des états très
très très compliqué très inégalitaire
par rapport au reste du territoire
oui si on s'y et cie s'ils ont
effectivement ce ce label contre la
politique de la ville c'est qu'il
nécessite non seulement l'aide de leur
propre ville mais aussi l'aide de
l'agglomération danse et je le répète
une compétence obligatoire la politique
de m voilà donc on a mobilisé plus d'un
près d'un million trois cent mille euros
l'année dernière du coup les choses
changent les choses bougent positivement
à saint quentin en yvelines
alors est ce que les choses bougent
positivement lentement mais j'espère
sûrement les problèmes il faut les
prendre sur le long terme
et dès le départ c'est à dire des dés
l'école parce qu'on le sait bien c'est
on se forme à la république quand on va
bien à l'école de la république est
alors moins là dedans que j'approuve
tout à fait ce qui a été ce qui a été
préconisée par jean louis borloo ce qui
est préconisé par le ministre de
l'éducation nationale alors la
scolarisation des enfants à deux ans je
suis un petit peu plus mitigé sur un peu
plus mitigé sur les deux compositions
oui tout à fait les deux ont baladé deux
ans je vais en tiges et pourquoi pas ce
que je trouve que un enfant à deux ans
est vraiment très petit il a besoin de
structures qu'ils soient dans une
structure autre que dans qu'au sein de
sa famille
qui plus est il faut que la famille
aille bien
c'est une chose mais que ce ne soit pas
une structure où on accueille 29 30
enfants voire 32
alors c'est vrai qu'a été mis en place
depuis cette année les le début
doublement des classes ils veulent
étendre même justement aux maternelles
voilà donc pourquoi pas je comprends
tout à fait la philosophie
peut-être que ça allait comme beaucoup
le principal oui le moyen d'accès y
arrive action et est le vrai lien qui
vous tire vers le haut parce qu'on
apprend à l'école et on apprend surtout
et moi j'ai toujours été une fervente
défenseure de 2 de l'école de la
république parce que parce qu'on a de
bons enseignants parce qu'ils se donnent
du mal à être plus de moyens sociaux
nerf de la guerre on va pas alors nous a
fait bien sûr c'est le nerf de la guerre
comme le dit et on a les moyens alors
est-ce qu'on a les moyens
moi je pense qu on a surtout peut-être
besoin de former davantage de monde
voilà on pourra pas dédoubler des
classes comme ça en claquant du doigt
d'ailleurs ça c'est bien vu cette année
il n'y a pas encore beaucoup de beaucoup
de villes qui sont comment dire qu'ils
sont traités dans ce cadre là donc il
faut plus plus d'enseignants ou une
répartition différente enfin en tout cas
il faut trouver une solution parce que
qui dit formation dit aussi du coup un
peu de temps si les choses doivent
démarrer relativement vite en il nous
faut il nous faut du monde leurs
magasins
donc voila mais moi j'y crois je voulais
vous qu'avez-vous notre une autre
proposition en rapport avec l'éducation
c'est celle de créer une école des
leaders sur le modèle de l'ena mais du
coup pour pour les banlieues est ce que
c'est une bonne idée
selon vous ou alors certains semblent
déjà la dénoncer avec une discrimination
positive pas forcément bienvenu quel est
votre point de vue moi j'ai déjà je
n'aime pas l'expression de
discrimination positive
excusez moi non mais ce n'est pas de
votre faute elle a été employée ya déjà
de nombreuses années
voilà parce que je trouve que c'est une
espèce de balance ça qui me justement
qui n'est pas équilibré en ski c'est
comme ça que je ressens une autre
proposition se crée une henin on va dire
pour les bleus
moi je trouve qu'il vaut mieux que tout
le monde aille au même endroit c'est à
dire qui a pas de raison que ça plutôt
rester là voilà que tout le monde puisse
accéder aux mêmes écoles et c'était
enfin souvenez vous quand même sous
nicolas sarkozy savait était année c'est
qui avait été fait et qui a quand même
réussi à certains donc je pense qu'il
vaut mieux qu'on continue dans ce sens
là et dès ce mais ça c'est pas propre
aux villes qui sont en contrat de ville
ses propres à toutes les villes dans
toutes les villes on a des enfants plus
brillant que d'autres c'est juste la vie
et donc je pense que alors dans ces cas
là effectivement pour les villes
question de contrats de ville
il faut peut-être faire en sorte de de
faire sortir ses enfants du lot et de
leur permettre un accès facilité aux
grandes écoles
parce que pas de raison mais crée encore
quelque chose de parallèle c'est un peu
dommage l'idée de 211 vies qu'elle est
quand même une indivisible
justement la république c'est l'idée de
ces la remettre au coeur des quartiers
de certains quartiers on parle souvent
c'est un titre générique mais d'un
rapport d'un plan de la dernière chance
alors c'est une facilité de langage mais
concrètement si ça ne marche pas ce coup
là qu'est ce qui pourrait se passer
qu'est ce qui pourrait être la suite je
sais que vous êtes optimiste vous le
disiez pas pessimiste mais qu'est ce qui
pourrait se passer ensuite si si rien
n'est fait dans les années à venir
selon vous est-ce qu'on pourrait avoir
de l'escroc c'est sûr qu'on ne peut pas
on ne peut pas rester les bras croisés à
se dire avec ce qu'on fait c'est déjà
pas si mal
il faut peut-être justement révisé et
c'est le but du rapport de jean louis
borloo réviser un certain nombre de
choses qui n'ont pas marché il faut le
constater après qu' à la baguette
magique malheureusement j'ai peur que
personne ne l'est c'est l'ensemble des
acteurs doivent se mobiliser des rails
dans celle d un côté le tout à fait le
développement économique ce qui se passe
à l'heure actuelle déjà par rapport au
contrat de ville 1 il faut que tout le
monde soit mobilisé il faut que les élus
quelle que soit leur étiquette et c'est
le cas d'ailleurs s'entendent pour dire
voilà là il faut qu'on essaye d'avancer
en faisant ça ça et ça et je pense que
là il n'y a pas de vins rares sont ceux
qui vont trouver à redire sa vie en ce
qui concerne baguette magique en
annonces il n'y a pas de baguette
magique mais mais il faut ce qu'il faut
savoir cesser d'augmenter les uns les
autres ils rester optimistes nous allons
vous restez avec nous on passe tout de
suite au résumé de l'actualité de la
semaine d'accord
l lundi jean jacques brot est devenu le
19e préfet des yvelines celui que la
presse a nommé un temps le préfet des
réfugiés a pris ses fonctions à
versailles après le départ de serge mans
vend quelques jours auparavant ce
dernier est resté en poste 2 ans et 8
mois dans les yvelines un territoire que
connaît son successeur les détails dorés
lire 11 premiers pas sur le terrain en
tant que préfet des yvelines pour jean
jacques brot après un parcours riche qui
lui a permis notamment de travailler en
outre mer ou encore au japon
retour dans un département qu'il connaît
bien j'ai eu la chance d'y être étudiant
à hec ya quelques années dit passer mon
permis de conduire à versants j'habitais
à jouy en josas comme vous l'avez
compris au vésinet aussi ultérieurement
dont je connais un peu le département je
connais plusieurs personnalités
éminentes de ce département show très
heureux d'y être en poste même si jean
jacques brot ne sait pas encore combien
de temps durera son exercice à la tête
de la préfecture des yvelines
il connaît d'ores et déjà les enjeux de
notre département
il ya des dossiers de sociétés
extrêmement important des dossiers
d'urbanisme des dossiers religieux voilà
sont des questions graves
qui mérite un grand investissement est
d'abord de ma part beaucoup d'humilité
de modestie
jean jacques brot succède à serge morvan
une fonction qu'il aura exercé pendant
deux ans et huit mois et qui aura marqué
sa mémoire
malheureusement il ya eu l'attentât de
magnanville j'ai passé la nuit dans
cette rue
vraiment je ne vais pas m'étendre lamé
et je veux pas revenir là-dessus mais
c'était très difficile
l'ancien préfet dû quitter ses fonctions
vendredi dernier non sans un petit
pincement au coeur
bon jeu principal regret c'est de partir
je serais bien rester encore longtemps
dans les yvelines comme préfet des
yvelines
il ya encore tellement de choses à faire
nommé commissaire général à l'égalité
des territoires serge normand aura en
charge la préfiguration de la future
agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires
susanne blank de questions très
rapidement puisque en tant qu'élu local
vous connaissez vous avez souvent un
féroé au préfet quels souvenirs vous
garderez de serge morvan et est ce que
vous connaissez aussi le nouveau préfet
jean jacques brot
alors de serge n'en vend qu'est ce que
je peux dire de lui que c'était
quelqu'un vraisemblablement de très
ouvert
moi je suis pas en lien direct puisque
voilà c'est plutôt l'aube ce sont les
maires voilà tout à fait
quelqu'un d'ouvert c'est ce que j'ai pu
constater en tout cas avec tout ce qui
s'est passé et puis aussi quelqu'un qui
est inquiète et attentif au dossier des
communes quelle qu'elle soit voilà alors
quand à monsieur brome et je lui
souhaite
la serbie n'est rejeté la cérémonie oui
tout à fait j'étais à la cérémonie
m'enfin bon dans ces cas là ce n'est pas
là où on échange beaucoup tout le monde
de tout le monde vote à l'occasion et
bien sûr parce qu'il ya des aura des
déplacements dans ce département des
yvelines demande du gouvernement donc on
va là on va le voir il a des spécialités
j'ai bien entendu donc il en faut il
faut il avala il l'a été spécialiste des
réfugiés donc dans le département c'est
suivra c'est important possible ce prêt
merci beaucoup
suzanne grandais venu et d'avoir répondu
à toutes nos questions vous êtes sur le
rappel vice-présidente de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge de
la politique de la ville et adjointe
déléguée à la vie scolaire à montigny le
bretonneux
merci à vous et bon ok merci à vous ah
ben une cérémonie a marqué la fin de
stage des tout premiers cadets de la
gendarmerie ils sont issus du lycée
blériot de trappes et de celui du vexin
achard dans le val d'oise mickaël
millero a suivi l'événement une première
en ile de france ce vendredi 20 avril
une cérémonie a été organisée sur le
camp de ben pour récompenser la fin de
stage de la première promotion des
cadets de la gendarmerie de la région
parisienne
c'est un symbole les cérémonies
militaires sont ont une portée
symbolique pour marquer leur intégration
et leur appartenance à la grande famille
à la grande communauté gendarmerie cette
année quinze lycéens âgés de 17 à 21 ans
ont intégré cette filière d'excellence
ils ont reçu leur diplôme devant leurs
proches ça fait plaisir de rendre fiers
nous
nos aînés nos parents nous notre famille
nos cadres sa tête et lire les futures
générations ainsi engagé aussi donc ce
serait c'est un très grand honneur pour
les soutenir l'ex boxeur jean marc
mormeck est actuellement délégué
interministériel à l'égalité des chances
des français d'outre-mer s'est rendu sur
place en tant que parrain de la
promotion
moi je suis très content de voir cette
jeunesse ou quand on parle positivement
aujourd'hui qui font des choses et on
parle beaucoup de jeunes qui font des
choses négatives mais aussi vous parler
des jeunes qui s'investissent et qui
veulent faire les choses prochaine étape
pour les lycéens de la promotion le
baccalauréat dans quelques semaines une
fois leur diplôme obtenu les intégrerons
pour la plupart la gendarmerie ils ne
sont plus mensuels mais trimestriels les
derniers chiffres du chômage ont été
dévoilés cette semaine et la tendance
est négative pour le département des
yvelines le chômage augmente de 0,9 pour
cent pour la catégorie à c'est-à-dire
celles qui concernent les personnes sans
aucune activité dans le département le
nombre de demandeurs d'emploi de cette
catégorie justement s'établit à 65 1210
au premier trimestre 2010 8 c'est la
plus forte augmentation en ile de france
devant les hauts-de-seine le chômage
baisse
en revanche dans le département du val
de marne au le val d'oise est des
travaux sont actuellement en cours à
l'église saint victor de guyancourt
c'est la dernière phase de la
restauration de l'édifice est datant du
xiième siècle elle a débuté le 5 mars
dernier et devrait se terminer courant
mai les derniers travaux concernent la
toiture du bâtiment un reportage de
nicolas landry bientôt la fin de vingt
ans de restauration des travaux pour
redonner une jeunesse à l'église saint
victor de guyancourt
la dernière phase concerne la toiture du
bas côté de l'édifice datant du xiième
siècle une intervention menée par un
cabinet d'architecturé spécialisé dans
le patrimoine historique
la pente est temps
inférieure ou au pourcentage de mise en
oeuvre de la tuile plate traditionnelle
qu'on met en oeuvre actuellement on
était obligé de réaliser une sous
toiture en zinc c'est les travaux
d'étanchéité de la toiture puisqu'il y
avait des infiltrations d'eau est
maintenant à ce jour on a réalisé
l'ensemble de la toiture
oui ça veut dire que sauf accident
particulier on va être tranquille pour
une période de voix un siècle voir aussi
avec l'ennemi l'église saint victor a
connu une longue cure de rajeunissement
de son intérieur à l'installation du
chauffage à la toiture et au parvis
devant le bâtiment
l'investissement total de la ville
avoisine les 1,5 million d'euros il
fallait faire toute façon comme c'est un
monument historique veut absolument que
la ville s'engage à restaurer l'église
l'important c'est de voir avant et après
est ce que cela attire beaucoup de
personnes pour venir à cette église
c'est quand même une église qui est de
moyen âge qui est à deux cols du 12e
siècle
allez pour ceux déjà qu'ils font qui
suivent le cul et puis il ya aussi le
fait je vous dis sympa à un bâtiment
important quand même les bâtisses
historiques un domaine important pour la
commune chaque année la ville engage
600000 euros dans son budget pour
l'entretien du patrimoine
mercredi jour de sortie au cinéma jour
de casting aussi à trappes l'équipe du
prochain film avec omar sy rechercher sa
sofia c'est le rôle de la fille du
trappistes dans la nouvelle comédie
réalisée par michel hazanavicius miquel
et demi d'euros et camille lambert était
sur place regarde et écoute
c'est très gentil d'accord mais je veux
pas voir quelqu'un
enfin si tu veux tu pourrais premier
casting pour chérel le temps de quelques
minutes elle devient sofia une enfant
drôle espiègle qui sera la fille d'omar
sy dans un nouveau film pourquoi tu peux
tu oublies avant son rôle
bonjour avec omar sy est vrai parce que
j'aime
bien faire des du cinéma une ambition
partagée par de nombreuses petites
filles âgées de 7 à 12 ans le casting se
déroulait à trappes ville d'origine de
l'acteur c'est bon c'était bien on m'a
pris en photo moi demandez guérin tests
et voilà c'est ma tête il motive ma
fille elle regarde même sur sa chaîne à
des portables et ça fait plaisir
on cherche le personnage ya des passages
test dans le texte ya un moment y'a que
le personnage qui saura dire comme il
faut et c'est la vérité du cassis terre
c'est après l'accumulation quand on a vu
beaucoup de gens on commence à en savoir
plus son personnage on sait qu elle est
marrante on sait que elle rigole bien
avec son père
la comédie intitulée le prince oublier
sera réalisé par michel hazanavicius
oscarisée en 2012 pour the artist
ce nouveau film avec omar sy sera tourné
cet été 2010 8 en région parisienne on
referme cette émission avec une bonne
action à présent près de 800 millions de
tonnes de déchets sont produits chaque
année en france beaucoup se retrouvent
malheureusement dans la nature
pour y parer en avril le comité
départemental de la randonnée pédestre
des yvelines invite les clubs à
participer à la randonnée est une
opération de nettoyage des sentiers
camille lambert bouteilles en verre sacs
plastiques cartons ces déchets peuvent
mettre plusieurs centaines d'années à
disparaître dans la nature
armés de gants et de sacs poubelles
c'est 15 randonneurs de la ls elancourt
ont prévu de nettoyer les abords du
sentier sont majoritairement sur le bord
des routes et aux abords des villes est
en fait chaud les chemins surtout le jeu
dès qu'on s'éloigne de ville le chemin
sont relativement propres fait les
randonneurs sont des gens qui respectent
la nature
départs lancés au mesnil saint denis à
peine quelques mètres et déjà détruit
veille et plastique plastic
l'association participe à l'opération
rando net lancé par le comité de la
randonnée pédestre des yvelines un moyen
de sensibiliser le public au respect de
la nature
le trajet se poursuit jusqu'à l'église
de lévis en joker bouteilles et autres
bombes du papier d'alu du plastique
hochart papier c'est principalement ça
les petits morceaux de plastique c'est
pas énorme comme collecte positive du
coup oui pour les chemins sur les
chemins hausse avec sont positifs
un maigre butin synonyme de bonnes
nouvelles pour la nature car chaque
année près de 800 millions de tonnes de
déchets sont produits en france
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo autour
de l'actualité en direct lundi à 18h sur
l'antenne de tv et 60 18 d'ici là restez
connectés et informés grâce à notre site
internet et applications tv 78 bon
week-end à tous et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]